hallo leute heute wollen wir euch einmal
die 20 populärsten nachnamen in
deutschland vorstellen und zeigen wie
man die richtig ausspricht
ihr kennt das wahrscheinlich im alltag
in deutschland hört man oft diese
typischen alten deutschen namen wie
schmidt müller oder schulz vielleicht
müsst ihr mal wo anrufen oder bei eurem
nachbarn klingeln und dann ist es
nützlich die richtig aussprechen zu
können
außerdem werden wir in diesem video auch
etwas allgemein über die aussprache des
deutschen lernen und über typische
fehler die man machen kann
los gehts nummer eins der aller aller
populärste nachname im deutschen ist der
name müller
ihr kennt diesen namen bestimmt und habe
den schon oft gehört vielleicht kennt
ihr den berühmten fußballspieler thomas
müller oder hat vielleicht nachbarn der
müller heißt und diesen namen gibt es
natürlich auch in anderen ländern es
gibt zum beispiel im amerikanischen oder
englischen das eingedeutschte maler es
gibt aber auch die englische variante
müller
denn dieser name müller geht auf eine
berufsbezeichnung zurück und zwar wurden
so im mittelalter die menschen genannt
die eine mühle hatten und gemahlen haben
also wenn man gewürze oder mehl
hergestellt hat und das wurde dann
gemahlen diese menschen nannte man
müller
was muss man bei der aussprache beachten
die häufigsten fehler sind zum beispiel
bei englischen muttersprachlern dass man
dieses er am ende über betont also dass
man sagt vielleicht müller oder müller
dollar das macht man im deutschen nicht
eigentlich kann man sich immer merken im
deutschen wenn man ein ehe er am ende
hat dass man das ganz oft wie ein
ausspricht also müller
das hört sich genauso an als würde am
ende einfach ein a stehen und nicht ein
müller das andere was man vielleicht
falsch machen kann ist dieses öl das
dass ein kurzes im deutschen gibt es
diese regel wenn man zwei konsonanten
hat dann wird ein vokal kurz gesprochen
und in einigen sprachen sowie zum
beispiel polnisch oder russisch kann das
unbekannt sein dass man zwischen kurzen
und langen vokalen unterscheidet und so
könnte man vielleicht sogar etwas hören
wie müller oder so aber das wäre auch
ein fehler also es muss wirklich ein
kurzes sein und kein ärger am ende das
betont wird müller
der nächste populäre nachname ist mein
nachname nämlich schmidt ihr habt
bestimmt schon ganz oft im deutschen den
namen schmidt gehört und dieser name hat
interessanterweise verschiedene
schreibweisen es gibt schmidt mit dt
schmidt mit tt und schmidt mit nur mit
de sowie mein nachname der wird nämlich
nur mit dem gesprochen
sie werden aber alle gleich
ausgesprochen sie sind also homophon und
wenn man diese verschiedenen
schreibweisen kombiniert ist schmidt
sogar eigentlich der populärste name und
noch häufiger als müller schmidt geht
auch auf eine berufsbezeichnung zurück
nämlich auf den schmied man kann also
davon ausgehen dass irgendwann in meiner
familie vor hunderten von jahren die
leute mal eisen bearbeitet haben und
vielleicht in einer schmiede gearbeitet
haben
die amish erzählt mir gerade von hinter
der kamera
dass schmidt gar nicht so ein besonderer
name ist auch weil dieser name früher
ganz oft menschen gegeben wurde die
keinen namen hatten es ist angeblich ein
sogenannter container namen
der auch einfach an leute verteilt
wurden die einen nachnamen brauchten
das klingt wie ein banner mythos janisch
aber ich werde es trotzdem hier erwähnen
falls leute daran zweifeln dass es so
viele schmiede gab in deutschland
vielleicht sind meine vorfahren auch gar
keine schmiede der dritt populärste
nachname in deutschland ist schneider
schneider ist auch eine
berufsbezeichnung das sind nicht
menschen die kleidung hergestellt haben
und schneider ist genauso wie schmidt
vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig
auszusprechen denn man hat dieses sch
eigentlich ist es nicht so schwierig man
kann sich merken sch ist immer also ein
weiches und das was danach kommt dass
wir mit gesprochen nämlich schnell also
man sagt zum beispiel schmidt schneider
und bei dem schneider ist noch eine
andere besonderheit die manchmal
schwierig ist für deutsch lernte es gibt
dieses und es gibt auch ie und das wird
ganz häufig verwechselt ist immer ein
schneider und je
diese folge andersrum das wäre schnyder
also das darf man nicht verwechseln da
muss man immer darauf achten wie ist
immer ein und am ende habt ihr wieder
dieses jahr also schneider wird
eigentlich gesprochen wie schneit und am
ende 1 a
schneider die plätze vier bis sechs sind
fischer weber und meier
ihr seht dieses er am ende ist immer
wieder dort fischer mayer und weber und
wieder haben wir hier einige
berufsbezeichnungen ein fischer der
fische es gibt dazu auch einen lustigen
wie nennt man das ja aber diese
diese zungenbrecher es gibt diesen
zungenbrecher fischers fritze frisch
fischt frische fische frische fische
fischt frische fische was es eben ein
zungenbrecher man verhaspelt sich mit
der zunge frische fische fischers sitzt
fast geschafft fischer ist jemand der
fischstein weber ist jemand der webt und
ein neuer der ist eigentlich eher dass
es jemand der früher so etwas war wie
ein hausmeister oder ein verwalter auf
größeren höfen
übrigens wenn ihr diese deutsche
aussprache mal richtig intensiv selbst
trainieren möchtet dann würde ich euch
unbedingt unsere app ceiling empfehlen
denn auf sie lang haben wir das
tatsächlich so aufbereitet dass ihr neue
vokabeln setzte und grammatik
kennenlernen könnt aber gleichzeitig
werdet ihr immer dazu aufgefordert jeden
satz und jedes wort noch einmal zu
wiederholen und ihr könnt eure stimme
dann selber aufnehmen ihr könnt jeden
satz noch einmal nach sprechen und dann
tatsächlich eure eigene stimme hören und
das ist sehr wertvoll wenn man deutsch
lernt dann gerade am anfang hat man
vielleicht ein bisschen angst zu
sprechen oder vielleicht etwas falsch
aus gesprächen und durch diese methode
dass ihr selber nach spricht aber dann
auch hört und analysiert wie eure stimme
klingt im vergleich zum muttersprachler
könnt ihr gerade am anfang viele
fortschritte mit der deutschen
aussprache machen nummer sieben auf der
liste der populärsten nachnamen in
deutschland ist wagner auch eine
berufsbezeichnung denn ein wagner war
jemand der früher wagen hergestellt hat
wagen ein fahrzeug wagner
dieser wagen mache und das nächste ist
nummer 8 der bäcker becker wird meistens
mit ece r geschrieben
mit einer weile als nachname die
berufsbezeichnung ist pck er also becker
ist heute die berufsbezeichnung aber
auch die namen die mit e geschrieben
werden gehen eigentlich meistens auf
diese berufsbezeichnung zurück und sie
werden auch fast ähnlich ausgesprochen
bäcker becker also eigentlich gibt es
gar keinen unterschied zwischen den l
und den laut oder jannis bäcker becker
und beim wagner
da seht ihr dass das hier lang
ausgesprochen wird im gegensatz zu den
bei bikern wagner am ende wieder richtig
nicht dieses er über betonen und becker
kurz se
das liegt daran weil es dort das ck gibt
im deutschen mit meistens ein ck
gesprochen oder geschrieben wenn man
zeigen möchte dass das ein doppel
konsonant ist c a gehört ganz oft
zusammen und man sieht seltener ein kk
nacheinander so wie es zum beispiel im
niederländischen üblich ist also ihr
könnt euch merken immer wenn ein vokal
vor einem ck ist oder einem tt dann wird
er immer kurz gesprochen sowie bekam
schmidt nummer 9
schulz diesem namen habt ihr vielleicht
auch schon öfters gehört schulz der
schuld geht auf diese berufsbezeichnung
des schultheiß zurück und ein schultheiß
war jemand der früher schulden
eingetrieben hat also der hatte zb die
aufgabe für einen herren oder einen
fürsten in den gemeinden schulden oder
abgaben einzusammeln was gibt es
besonderes an dem schulz
das ist hier auch kurz weil das
eigentlich eine einzige silbe ist man
kann das nicht trennen
schulz dass es eine silbe und deshalb
gibt es dieses kurze ich spreche es noch
zwei mal für euch aus langsam und
schnell schulz schulz platz 10 auf
dieser liste ist der name hoffmann
hoffmann ist sehr ähnlich wie der name
meyer und es bezeichnet eigentlich
jemanden der auf einem hof wohnt oder
diesen hof verwaltet es kann auch so
etwas sein wie ein bauer eigentlich der
auf einem hof arbeitet und auch bauer
ist übrigens ein populärer deutscher
nachname und zwar auf unserer liste ich
schau mal nach nummer 13 der populärsten
namen hoffmann wird so gesprochen
hoffmann
es sind also zwei selben und ihr seht
wieder dieses doppel f deswegen ist das
so kurz man sagt also nicht hofmann
sondern hoffmann
obwohl es von diesem namen hof kommt und
ihr seht hof spreche ich anders aus es
gibt hier nur ein f und deshalb sagt man
das lange oberhof und hofft damit kannst
du das auch machen hof und man ist
genauso man ist mit einem kurzen a und
einem doppelten am ende hofft man nummer
elf wieder eine berufsbezeichnung der
schäfer das ist ein mensch der sich um
scharfe kümmert und beim schäfer wird
das e lang gesprochen anders als beim
bäcker sie hat vielleicht den
unterschied schäfer bekam schäfer bekam
und bei schaefer hört ihr dieses er
richtig schön beim bäcker habe ich eben
erzählt dass das l und das eh fast
genauso ist weil das ein kurzer vocalist
becker schäfer
platz zwölf ist ein name den ihr
vielleicht auch schon mal außerhalb
deutschlands gehört habt und das ist der
koch ein koch ist auch heute noch eine
berufs bezahlt
es ist einfach ein mensch der kocht und
was gibt es besonderes an der aussprache
koch das ist ein kurzes oh man sagt also
nicht hoch und das ch am ende dass es
auch besonders ihr habt vielleicht schon
mal gehört dass man das ch anders
ausspricht je nachdem welcher vokal
davor ist bei a&o hört man dieses
kratzige dieses auch noch krach dach und
bei i und ii zum beispiel hat man dieses
weiche dieses ich da hoch
janosch war gar nicht klar er sitzt
gerade hinter der kamera
dass so viele der dieser populären
deutschen nachnamen von
berufsbezeichnungen kommen aber auch die
nächsten beiden sind tatsächlich wieder
berufe nämlich der bauer auf platz 13
haben wir schon darüber gesprochen und
der richter auf platz 14 ein bauer ist
jemand der auf dem land arbeitet oder
vielleicht 40 tipps oder gemüse anbaut
hier ist zu beachten dass ihr dieses
auto hat wird immer wie ausgesprochen
bauen und am ende habt ihr das er aber
dass er wird hier wieder nicht betont
also es ist eigentlich wie ein a man
könnte auch sagen bauer bauer beim
richter hört ihr jetzt dieses weiche ch
ihr habt jetzt das i vor den ch und
deswegen sagt ihr richter und richter
richter ist korrekt richter platz 15 und
16 jahren öfter wirst du überrascht sein
sind ausnahmsweise keine
berufsbezeichnungen sondern sie sind
eigenschaften also zumindest platz 15
denn dieser name ist klein vielleicht
habt ihr schon mal diesen nachnamen
gehört klein es gibt auch den nachnamen
lange zum beispiel und damit hat man
einfach menschen bezeichnet die
besonders klein oder besonders groß
waren also der name klein ist früher für
leute gewesen die kleine
und das interessante ist bei der
aussprache hier weder des e ii klein man
sagt nicht queen oder sowas sondern
klein und dann haben wir noch das wort
wolf wolf ist eigentlich ein vorname
gewesen und heutzutage ist der vorname
vielleicht nicht mehr so populär
es gibt auch noch einige kombinierte
vornamen wie wolfram oder wolfgang und
dieser name das ist ja eigentlich ein
tier der wolf wurde aber auch manchmal
für nachnamen angenommen das sind dann
aber keine menschen die mit wölfen
gelebt haben sondern ist es eigentlich
von dem vornamen wolf auf den nachnamen
übertragen worden
platz 17 ist ein ganz interessanter name
der name schröder
vielleicht habt ihr den schon mal gehört
denn wir hatten früher einen
bundeskanzler namens gerhard schröder
der ist vielleicht ein bisschen
schwierig auszusprechen dass oesterle
der schröder ist auf jeden fall ein
interessanter name denn er könnte aus
verschiedenen bedeutungen kommen
das könnte entweder ein schneider sein
denn im niederdeutschen hat man für
schneidern auch ein anderes wort benutzt
nämlich dass schröder
zumindest habe ich das gerade gelesen
schrödl und es gibt aber auch den beruf
des notars und niemand der etwas
geschrotet hat das war jemand das wäre
vielleicht ein beruf für janisch gewesen
im mittelalter der hat bier und wein in
fässern transportiert und seine ganze
aufgabe war wein und bier aus einem
keller in einem fass in einen wagen zu
transportieren und wenn es dann am ort
angekommen ist das fass wieder aus dem
wagen heraus zu rollen in den keller und
das nannte man schroten nummer 18 und 19
sind wieder nachnamen die von
eigenschaften kommen so ähnlich wie
klein gibt es auch die namen neumann als
bezeichnung für jemanden der neu ist und
schwarz auch ein formular populärer name
in deutschland für jemanden der schwarze
haare hat wenn man also keinen
besonderen beruf hatte dann hat man
vielleicht einfach eigenschaften benutzt
um nachnamen zu vergeben
also die namen neu man neu ist
vielleicht interessant dass er da
spricht man aus neumann und schwarz dass
es vielleicht ein wort was nicht so
einfach auszusprechen ist man hat das
sch dann das wäre und dann das aez
schwarz man hört dass schwarz oder man
hört dieses ehre manchmal stärker
manchmal weniger je nachdem wo man in
deutschland ist in bayern und anderen
südlichen regionen da betont man dass er
ein bisschen stärker
da hat man vielleicht sowas wie schwarz
oder vielleicht auch im rheinland in der
gegend von köln betont man dieses er
sehr stark
in anderen regionen hört man das
vielleicht kaum da hat man so etwas wie
schwarz schwarz also neben langes a
quasi platz 20 der letzte name für heute
ist der zimmermann ein zimmermann ist
jemand der mit holz arbeitet und man
kann sich das ganz bildlich vorstellen
der zimmer macht also der macht
eigentlich baukonstruktionen manchmal
auch dächer und arbeitet vor allem mit
holz und bis heute ist der zimmermann
eine berufsbezeichnung in deutschland
und dieses wort ist vielleicht auch
besonders man hat dieses z am anfang im
deutschen sprich man das z sowie ein ts
aus zimmermann und man hat dann wieder
ein kurzes denn man hat danach dieses
doppelte m und nacht vor dem doppel
konsonanten kommt das kurze ii
man sagt also nicht zimmermann sondern
zimmermann zimmermann
das war unser video für heute die amish
hatte gerade die idee dass ich als
nächstes ein video über die lustigsten
deutschen namen machen und mal die
witzigsten namen vorstellen
die amish feld
worum wurden gibt es jemanden der wurm
heißt ich glaube ich habe gesehen
haase gibt es auch im deutschen okay
wenn ihr möchtet dass wir mal ein video
machen zu den lustigsten deutschen
nachnamen dann schreibt uns einen
kommentar und wenn wir genug kommentare
bekommen dann machen wir das tatsächlich
was ich euch am ende noch sagen möchte
ist dass ich einige links hier unten in
die infobox stelle
denn bei wikipedia kann man zu den
meisten nahmen auch sehen wo die
besonders häufig in deutschland
vorkommen was ganz interessant ist denn
menschen manche namen sind vielleicht
populärer in norddeutschland
westdeutschland süddeutschland guckt
euch das mal an wenn ihr mehr lernen
wollt über die deutschen nachnamen danke
fürs zuschauen und bis bald fischers
fritze frisch fischt frische fische
frische fische fischt frische fische
frische fische fischers fritz